Steve Raucci. Let's just start with something that Steve Raucci was really good at-- cutting energy costs. He was legendary. If you worked in the Schenectady School District, you knew that if you wanted to turn on extra lights or make some illicit toast in your classroom, there'd be hell to pay. Unauthorized coffee makers, microwaves-- forbidden.
史蒂夫·劳奇（Steve Raucci）。我们就从史蒂夫·劳奇特别擅长的一件事说起——削减能源成本。他简直是个传奇。如果你在斯克内克塔迪学区工作，你就知道如果你想在教室里多开几盏灯，或者想偷偷烤个吐司，那后果可是不堪设想的。未经授权的咖啡机、微波炉——统统禁止。
I never saw this happen, but I heard reports of people's electric cords being just cut at the source so that they couldn't be used again. Just physically snipped in half. So we didn't want to cause trouble, so we just tried to live reasonably.
我没亲眼见过，但我听说有人甚至直接把电器的电源线剪断，让他们无法再使用。就是物理意义上的剪成两半。我们不想惹麻烦，所以只想安分守己地过日子。
At one point, Richard Agnello, a special education teacher, was working in the middle school and had this little office with no heat-- none. In winter, it would be 56 degrees in there. He borrowed a thermometer from a science classroom to check. He asked for heat repeatedly. Nothing happened, so he broke the rules, brought in a little space heater, which he would hide in a file cabinet at night. So one winter morning, he gets to work, and he turns on the space heater, hangs up his coat. Suddenly, Steve Raucci walks in and sees the heater.
有一次，特教老师理查德·阿涅洛（Richard Agnello）在中学工作时，有个没有暖气的小办公室——一点暖气都没有。冬天里面只有56华氏度（约13摄氏度）。他从科学教室借了一个温度计来测量。他多次要求供暖，但什么都没发生，于是他打破了规定，带了一个小暖风机，晚上就把它藏在档案柜里。一个冬天的早晨，他去上班，打开暖风机，挂好外套。突然，史蒂夫·劳奇走了进来，看到了那个暖风机。
Eyes bulging, and veins on his head throbbing. Started yelling at me and saying, what are you doing with that space heater here? You're not supposed to have that here? That's against district policy. And I-- kind of taken aback that someone would get this upset over a little heat in the room. And I said, you know what? You're right. And I'm not trying to be a scofflaw, but look at my thermometer. It's 57 degrees in here. And he didn't have much to say. He sputtered and fumed and said, well, you've got to get rid of that.
他双眼圆睁，额头的青筋暴起。他开始对我大吼大叫，说：“你在这儿搞什么暖风机？你不准在这儿放这个！这是违反学区规定的。”而我——我有点吃惊，竟然有人会为了房间里的一点暖气发这么大的火。我说：“你知道吗？你说得对。我不是想当个不守规矩的人，但看看我的温度计，这里才57华氏度（约14摄氏度）。”他没话说了，气得嘟嘟囔囔，说：“总之，你得把它弄走。”
The next day, Agnello is walking up a flight of stairs, and sees a maintenance worker coming down the stairs.
第二天，阿涅洛在走上楼梯时，看到一名维修工人正从楼梯上下来。
He's carrying my space heater in an arm, cradled like a football, and he's running down the stairs. And I saw him from about half a flash away, and I said, hey, what are you doing with my space heater? And he said, don't talk to me. Don't talk to me. Talk to my boss. And he ran out the front door, ran past me, jumped into the district van that was parked outside, and tore away from the building, just spewing rocks as he went.
他抱着我的暖风机，像夹着橄榄球一样，正跑下楼梯。我在大约半个闪光灯距离远的地方看见他，于是说：“嘿，你拿我的暖风机干什么？”他说：“别跟我说话。别跟我说话。去找我老板谈。”他跑出门外，从我身边跑过，跳进停在外面的学区货车里，飞快地开离了现场，扬起了一路碎石。
I got the thing tucked under my arm and I'm going down the stairs--
我夹着那东西走下楼梯——
That's John Lapointe Jr, the district electrician who'd been sent to remedy this very, very serious space heater infraction.
那是小约翰·拉普安特（John Lapointe Jr），学区的电工，他被派去解决这起“非常、非常严重”的暖风机违规事件。
And this guy goes-- right at the bottom of the stairs, I'm heading out to my truck-- hey, that's my space heater. Where you going with that? I go, you got to talk to facilities. You know, Steve Raucci in facilities. And I just kept going.
这人就在楼梯底部，我正准备去我的卡车那里——“嘿，那是我的暖风机。你把它带去哪儿？”我当时说：“你得去和后勤部门谈。就是后勤部的史蒂夫·劳奇。”然后我就径直走开了。
For the people who worked under Steve Raucci, this story's a dime a dozen. And it's got all the hallmarks of Raucci's style-- the temper, the fanatical control over every single detail around him, the pettiness, the comic strip antics, even the fact that workers were forbidden to talk to teachers when they were out on a job.
对于那些在史蒂夫·劳奇手下工作的人来说，这种事简直家常便饭。这事儿带有劳奇式风格的所有特征——坏脾气、对身边每一个细节的疯狂控制、小肚鸡肠、连环漫画式的搞怪行径，甚至包括工人在外面工作时被禁止与老师交谈。
Schenectady School District has a good reputation academically, and the people in town knew the usual things about their schools-- the test scores, the good teachers, the budget fights. What they didn't know was that a huge scandal was slowly coming to a boil in one of the least likely places, down Norwood Avenue, along the side of Mount Pleasant Middle School, behind the high chain link fence surrounding a parking lot filled with trucks and vans, an area called the pen.
斯克内克塔迪学区在学术上声誉良好，镇上的人也了解学校的一些常规情况——考试分数、优秀的教师、预算之争。但他们不知道的是，一个巨大的丑闻正在一个最不可能的地方缓慢发酵：顺着诺伍德大道（Norwood Avenue），沿着快乐山中学（Mount Pleasant Middle School）的一侧，在围住停车场的高大铁链栅栏后面，那里停满了卡车和货车，这块区域被称为“围栏”。
Alongside the pen there's a big garage where they store lawn mowers and tons of supplies. That's where the workers hang out-- the custodians and the maintenance guys. They were Steve Raucci's subjects who, only half-jokingly, called Steve the "King," or the "Doctor," or sometimes even just "God." Everybody who worked for him has an example of something that he did, something just off enough they've never forgotten it.
在“围栏”旁边有个大车库，存放着割草机和成堆的物资。那是工人们——管理员和维修工——常待的地方。他们是史蒂夫·劳奇的“臣民”，他们半开玩笑地称史蒂夫为“国王”、“医生”，有时甚至直接叫他“上帝”。每个为他工作的人都有一个关于他所作所为的例子，这件事怪异到让人终生难忘。
When I was in the restroom, he slid newspapers on fire underneath the door.
当我在洗手间时，他从门底下塞进燃烧的报纸。
He had eggs. I have chickens, so I'd bring eggs in for the guys. And he saw them in the fridge or something. He goes, oh, here. He makes the gal-- his secretary-- pick who he throws the egg at. She didn't want to pick anybody.
他有鸡蛋。我养鸡，所以我会带些鸡蛋给大伙儿。他在冰箱里还是什么地方看到了。他说：“哦，给你。”他让他的秘书挑选他要把鸡蛋扔向谁。她不想选任何人。
I was on my way home one day, and I see something smoking in the middle of the road as I'm approaching it with my van. And all of a sudden, this thing goes ba-boom. Scared the living daylights out of me. You know what I mean? This thing, when it went off, it shook the whole area. So I come to work the next morning. Steve's sitting there. He starts asking me, so anything exciting happen, or anything unusual happen? And I'm like, it was you?
有一天我在回家的路上，接近我的货车时，看到路中间有什么东西在冒烟。突然间，这东西“砰”的一声。吓得我魂飞魄散。你明白我的意思吗？这东西炸开时，整个区域都在震动。第二天早上我来上班，史蒂夫坐在那儿。他开始问我：“那么，昨天发生了什么刺激或不寻常的事情吗？”我当时想：原来是你干的？
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, how one guy came to be untouchable, how he grabbed power and dominated everybody around him, sometimes with fear, sometimes cruelty, playing by rules that he invented. And how people all around him, including people with the power to stop him, let it happen.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天节目的话题是，一个人是如何变得不可撼动、如何攫取权力并统治身边所有人的——有时通过恐惧，有时通过残暴，还通过他自己发明的规则。以及他周围的人，包括那些有权阻止他的人，是如何放任这一切发生的。
And what's so interesting about this is that all the intrigue and drama did not happen in a setting like national politics or big business. This guy wasn't a Harvey Weinstein with the power to make somebody a movie star. This is a study in tyranny writ small, Machiavellian scheming in the maintenance office of school district.
最有趣的是，所有这些阴谋和闹剧并非发生在国家政治或大企业那种环境中。这家伙不是那种有权让某人成为电影明星的哈维·韦恩斯坦（Harvey Weinstein）。这是一项关于“微观暴政”的研究，是发生在学区维修办公室里的马基雅维利式阴谋。
Act One of today's show is about what it was like at the height of Steve Raucci's power. Act Two is about how he fell. We first broadcast today's show years ago, when all this happened. This week is the 10th anniversary of Raucci's arrest. And he just did an interview with a reporter about what happened where he says some things he's never said. Some details of that at the end of the program. The reporter for our story is Sarah Koenig, who later became the host of the podcast Serial. And let's get right to it. Here's Sarah Koenig.
节目的第一部分讲的是史蒂夫·劳奇权力巅峰时期的情况。第二部分讲的是他如何倒台。我们第一次播出这期节目是在几年前事件发生时。本周是劳奇被捕十周年。他最近接受了一位记者的采访，讲述了发生的事情，其中说了一些他从未说过的话。节目最后会有相关细节。我们故事的记者是莎拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig），她后来成为了播客《Serial》的主持人。我们直接开始吧。这里是莎拉·科尼格。
Of course there are tyrannical, manipulative bullies everywhere, but Steve Raucci was special, a virtuoso. Schenectady County District Attorney Bob Carney is something of an expert on tough characters of all kinds. Since he's been DA, he's overseen the convictions of more than 80 murderers.
当然，到处都有暴虐、操纵人的恶霸，但史蒂夫·劳奇很特别，是个“专家”。斯克内克塔迪县地区检察官鲍勃·卡尼（Bob Carney）算得上是各类强硬角色的专家。他担任地区检察官以来，监督了80多名杀人犯的定罪。
And some of them did unspeakably bad things. But in terms of a person who bullies people, and studies the art of intimidation and coercion, I don't think there's anybody that compares with him because he made it the theme and the focus of his life.
其中一些人犯下了无法言喻的罪行。但就一个欺凌他人、研究恐吓和胁迫艺术的人而言，我认为没有人能和他相比，因为他把这变成了他人生的主题和焦点。
What also makes the Raucci affair unusual is that he got away with it, quietly, for decades. So that when he was finally arrested in February of 2009, charged with 26 felonies from weapons possession, to arson, to terrorism, the citizens of Schenectady were incredulous. Carl Strock, a writer for the Schenectady Daily Gazette, wrote dozens of columns about the case. And he's not someone who ever thought the school district could yield interesting news.
劳奇事件的另一个不寻常之处在于，他悄无声息地逍遥法外了几十年。所以当他在2009年2月最终被捕，并被指控犯有26项重罪，从非法持有武器到纵火、再到恐怖主义时，斯克内克塔迪的市民们简直不敢相信。《斯克内克塔迪日报公报》（Schenectady Daily Gazette）的撰稿人卡尔·斯特罗克（Carl Strock）曾写过数十篇关于此案的专栏。他从未想过学区能产生什么有趣的新闻。
Not only Schenectady School District, but any school district around here that I've heard of-- these are boring, boring places for a journalist. If a clerk sometimes embezzles $20 from the petty cash drawer, that would be a big event in a school district. School districts attract-- you know, it's kind of noble-minded people. And so my first reaction, and I think everybody's, was wow.
不仅是斯克内克塔迪学区，我听说过的任何学区——对记者来说都是枯燥、乏味的地方。如果有个职员偶尔从备用金抽屉里挪用20美元，那在学区里就是件大事。学区吸引的都是那些有高尚情操的人。所以我的第一反应，我想也是所有人的反应，是：“哇。”
How could this happen? How can you have a mid-level employee in the school district being sort of a terrorist, really? Vandalizing people's houses, threatening them bodily, and grabbing them physically, humiliating them. And all this that had been going on for years, how could this have happened?
这怎么可能发生？你怎能让学区的一名中层员工变成一个真正的恐怖分子？破坏人们的房子、威胁他们的人身安全、对他们动手动脚、羞辱他们。而这一切已经持续了多年，怎么可能发生？
Steve Raucci grew up in Schenectady. It's a small, mostly working class, middle class city about three hours north of Manhattan. He started working in the district in 1973, making $3.12 an hour as a laborer. He worked his way up to groundskeeper, then maintenance guy. And by the time his career ended 36 years later, he was in charge of all 21 of the district school buildings. He was 60 years old, married to his third wife, Shelley, no children, living in a modest condo.
史蒂夫·劳奇在斯克内克塔迪长大。这是一个距离曼哈顿北部约三小时车程的小城市，主要是工人阶级和中产阶级居住。他1973年开始在学区工作，当时是一名时薪3.12美元的劳工。他一路升职为场地管理员，然后是维修工。到他36年后职业生涯结束时，他负责管理学区全部21栋校舍。他当时60岁，与第三任妻子雪莉（Shelley）结婚，没有孩子，住在一套普通的公寓里。
The stories people tell about Steve's behavior-- and there are probably hundreds of stories-- fall into a few categories. First, humiliating hijinks. Second, insatiable control. And third, retribution-- reserved for those who didn't react well to the first and second categories. I talked to John Lapointe Jr, the electrician, Ellen Frederick, Steve's former secretary, Bryan Schaeffer, a district carpenter, and a few other people who didn't want their names used. They all said that humiliation was a daily event, and often creepily sexual. Here's Ellen Frederick.
人们讲述史蒂夫行为的故事——可能有数百个——可以归为几类。第一，羞辱人的恶作剧。第二，贪婪的控制欲。第三，报复——留给那些在前两类中反应不好的人。我采访了电工约翰·拉普安特（John Lapointe Jr）、史蒂夫的前秘书艾伦·弗雷德里克（Ellen Frederick）、学区木匠布莱恩·谢弗（Bryan Schaeffer）以及其他一些不想透露姓名的人。他们都说羞辱是每天都会发生的事，而且通常带有令人毛骨悚然的性意味。这是艾伦·弗雷德里克的讲述。
He walked around my desk, and walked behind me, pretended to grab my hair, pretending to drag me in his office, and bend me over his desk, and proceeded to-- he simulated-- we got it. We knew exactly what he was doing.
他走到我的办公桌旁，走到我身后，假装抓住我的头发，假装把我拖进他的办公室，把我按在他的办公桌上，然后开始——他模拟了全过程——我们懂的。我们清楚地知道他在干什么。
And then there was the so-called man game.
还有所谓的“男人游戏”。
He'd put his hand on a guy's thigh, and kind of jokingly wait for any sort of reaction from the person. Just because if you enjoyed that, perhaps you'd be gay.
他会把手放在男人的大腿上，半开玩笑地等待那人的任何反应。仅仅因为如果你享受这个，也许你就是同性恋。
Once he asked a young employee to show me a picture of his girlfriend, who was beautiful. So the guy did. The picture was on his phone. And Steve asked him to email it to him, and the guy said no. Steve asked again. And the kid said no. And then Steve suggested that if he so wanted that raise they'd talked about, he would send the photo. So the guy did. The next morning, a big blown-up copy of it was taped to the office whiteboard, along with a caption too disgusting to repeat. The kid was horrified.
有一次，他要求一名年轻员工向他展示他女朋友的照片，那个女孩很漂亮。于是那个人照做了。照片在他手机里。史蒂夫要求他发邮件给自己，那人拒绝了。史蒂夫又问了一次。那孩子说不。然后史蒂夫暗示，如果他想要他们谈好的加薪，就得把照片发过来。于是那人照做了。第二天早上，一张放大的照片被贴在了办公室的白板上，旁边还配了一句无法复述的恶心标题。那孩子吓坏了。
Steve's answer was, I didn't know you were coming in today. I thought you were off.
史蒂夫的回答是：“我不知道你今天会来。我还以为你休假呢。”
If you were out to breakfast with Steve-- and a core group of employees was compelled to attend these breakfasts-- he might pour a shaker of salt in your coffee when your back was turned, or sneak up on you in the bathroom and steal your glasses. Steve would open your paycheck and write something embarrassing on the back, or even the front.
如果你和史蒂夫一起吃早餐——一群核心员工不得不参加这些早餐会——你转过身后，他可能会往你的咖啡里倒一整罐盐，或者在洗手间偷袭你并偷走你的眼镜。史蒂夫会拆开你的工资单，在背面甚至正面写上一些让人尴尬的东西。
At morning meetings-- sometimes hour-long affairs at which Steve would read aggressive, prepared remarks, Soviet-style, to the 20 or so guys gathered-- he might bring up your personal problems, how your marriage was on the rocks, your wife cheating on you, apropos of nothing.
在早会上——有时长达一小时，史蒂夫会像苏联时期那样，向聚集在那里的20来个人宣读充满侵略性的准备好的发言稿——他可能会提到你的个人问题，比如你的婚姻触礁、你妻子出轨，尽管这些事毫无关联。
An older guy who'd since retired from the school told me, you can say a lot of it was funny, but it was funny like this. We were at a restaurant and he took his beer bottle and put the base of it halfway across the edge of the table, so it was teetering. At any moment, crash. And then it was a disaster, he said.
一位已经退休的学区老员工告诉我：“你可以说其中很多事很有趣，但那种有趣是这样的：我们在一家餐馆，他把啤酒瓶底放在桌沿的一半位置，让它摇摇欲坠。随时都可能摔下去。那将是一场灾难。”他说。
You don't do stuff like this-- slide flaming newsprint under a door, or pretend to have sex with your secretary-- unless you're sure you can get away with it. Steve was sure. He was methodical and utterly in charge. For one thing, he controlled work assignments for the 110 people he managed, and treated his department like a combination of an army unit and a fourth-grade classroom. If you messed up one of his many rules, even in a small way, he'd make you write, I will not do such and such, over and over on that whiteboard every day.
你不会做这种事——从门下塞入燃烧的报纸，或假装和秘书发生性关系——除非你确定能逃脱惩罚。史蒂夫很确定。他非常有条理，并且完全掌控局面。一方面，他控制着他管理的110人的工作分配，并把他的部门当作一支军队和一个四年级教室的结合体。如果你违反了他许多规定中的任何一条，哪怕只是小事，他都会让你在那个白板上每天一遍又一遍地写：“我不会再做某某事。”
You were supposed to arrive at 6:55 AM. If you came in at 7:00, the official start of the workday, he'd make you sign in late up at the admin office, in a different building a few streets away. Ellen Frederick, his secretary, was a favorite of Steve's for a while. She was the Faye Ray to his King Kong, except that he's actually a small, trim, chiseled guy who wore a brown weave in his gray hair until he had to shave it for prison.
你本应在早上6点55分到达。如果你在7点整，也就是官方上班时间进来，他会让你去几条街外另一栋楼的行政办公室签迟到。艾伦·弗雷德里克，他的秘书，曾一度是史蒂夫的最爱。她是他权力的“金刚”剧中的“菲伊·雷”（Faye Ray），只不过他实际上是个瘦小、精干、轮廓分明的人，留着棕色假发遮盖灰白头发，直到他入狱被迫剃光头。
Ellen was such a favorite that she even talked back to him sometimes. At meals, she always had to be at his side. He'd assign everyone else seats, as well. He'd tell her how he liked her to look-- hair, long and curly, skirts short, leggings. Sometimes the staff was told they weren't allowed to talk to her. She was his alone. But eventually, even she crossed him. And if you crossed Steve, you were done. She and a couple of other people in the office were having a casual conversation one day about romantic types. Steve asked Ellen what she meant, so she explained.
艾伦曾经是他的最爱，有时甚至会顶撞他。用餐时，她必须总是坐在他身边。他还会给其他人分配座位。他会告诉她他喜欢她什么样子——头发要长而卷，裙子要短，要穿紧身裤。有时员工被告知不准和她说话。她是他的专属物。但最终，连她也忤逆了他。如果你忤逆了史蒂夫，你就完了。有一天，她和办公室里的另外几个人在闲聊恋爱类型的话题。史蒂夫问艾伦是什么意思，于是她解释了。
You know what I mean. You like Susan Lucci. He was obsessed with Susan Lucci. He loved her. He had pictures of her underneath his little desk, his blotter. And I said, well, you're not my type. I like Matthew McConaughey. He's my type, whatever. Well, you thought that I just told him I put the knife right in his heart. His face turned beet red. His veins popped out of his neck. I mean, he couldn't even talk. He was just like, OK, that's enough. We're done here. So that was it. Two weeks later I was in a different office.
“你知道我的意思。你喜欢苏珊·卢奇（Susan Lucci）。”他痴迷苏珊·卢奇。他爱她。他把她的照片压在小桌子的吸墨纸下面。我说：“好吧，你不是我的菜。我喜欢马修·麦康纳（Matthew McConaughey）。他是我的菜，随便吧。”好吧，你以为我只是告诉他，我把刀插进了他的心脏。他的脸涨成了紫红色。脖子上的青筋暴起。我是说，他甚至说不出话来。他只是说：“好了，够了。我们到此为止。”就是这样。两周后我就被调到了另一个办公室。
Ellen was moved to a different building, different department, no questions asked. It wasn't a demotion, but it wasn't what she wanted. Other than Steve, she really liked her job in the maintenance department, had a lot of friends there. Administrators told her they were moving her for her own protection. They didn't explain what they meant. She told me she later heard Steve had threatened her at a meeting with administrators, saying if she doesn't go quietly, she knows what's going to happen to her, her house, and her family.
艾伦被调到了另一栋楼、另一个部门，没有任何解释。这不算降职，但也不是她想要的。除了史蒂夫之外，她真的很喜欢在维修部门的工作，那里有很多朋友。行政人员告诉她，调她是为她好，为了保护她。他们没解释是什么意思。她告诉我，后来听说史蒂夫在一次有行政人员参加的会议上威胁过她，说如果她不悄悄离开，她知道她自己、她的房子和她的家人会发生什么。
And all this time, no one said anything because if they did, they knew they'd face the same sort of retribution from Steve. People said they were afraid to talk sometimes for fear they'd accidentally say the wrong thing. Someone would report it back to Steve. He openly encouraged reporting back, rewarding gossip with time off or overtime pay. A district carpenter even made a wooden wedge of cheese which would end up in your mailbox if you'd been what Steve called a good rat.
而在这一切期间，没人说任何话，因为如果说了，他们知道自己会面临史蒂夫同样的报复。人们说他们有时不敢说话，担心万一说错话。有人会向史蒂夫打小报告。他公开鼓励告密，用休假或加班费来奖励八卦的人。一位学区木匠甚至做了一个木制的奶酪楔子，如果你是史蒂夫口中的“好内奸”，它最终会出现在你的邮箱里。
Steve flaunted his vengeance, his mastery of it. At a union holiday party in 2007, everyone dressed up, having a nice time. He stood up and asked for their attention so he could read a speech. Instead of a toast to all their hard work and the fun times to come, he issued a yuletide warning. If you criticize me behind my back, you will be very, very sorry.
史蒂夫炫耀他的报复心，他对报复的掌控力。在2007年的一次工会假日聚会上，大家盛装打扮，玩得很开心。他站起来要求大家注意，因为他要读一篇演讲稿。他没有为他们的辛勤工作和未来的快乐时光举杯，而是发出了一个圣诞警告：如果你在背后批评我，你会非常、非常后悔。
It doesn't matter if you say it while you're in a drugstore, a mall, or one of our schools. Unless you're talking to yourself, there's always a good chance of it leaking back to me.
不管你是在药店、商场还是我们的学校里说这些话，除非你在自言自语，否则总有很大的可能会传到我耳朵里。
Police found the text of the speech in Steve's computer when they seized it. That's Bob Carney reading, the district attorney who personally prosecuted Steve.
警察在没收史蒂夫的电脑时发现了这份演讲稿。那是鲍勃·卡尼在朗读，就是那位亲自起诉史蒂夫的地区检察官。
So you understand how important it is for me to protect myself with my responsibilities, I will mention the names of several people in our department that I have eliminated because they found out just how protective I can be. Some of you may remember them.
“为了让你们理解我履行职责时保护自己有多重要，我将提到部门里几名被我清理的人的名字，因为他们发现了我有多么强的自我保护能力。你们有些人可能还记得他们。”
If you're noticing a certain embattled tone, for Raucci, the maintenance department is an operatic drama of endless threats and intrigue. He can't trust anyone. He's constantly undermined by disloyal minions. You're either with Steve, or you're against Steve, he'd tell people. There is no, on the fence. Fence riders get hurt. He'd recite lines from Goodfellas and other tough guy movies, without irony, in conversations about routine office business. In his Christmas speech, he went on to denounce a bunch of people he'd eliminated, including these guys.
如果你注意到了一种四面楚歌的基调，对于劳奇来说，维修部门就是一场充满无尽威胁和阴谋的歌剧。他不能信任任何人。他不断被不忠的走狗削弱。他会告诉人们：你要么支持史蒂夫，要么反对史蒂夫。没有中间派。骑墙的人会受到伤害。他会在谈论日常办公室业务时，毫无讽刺地背诵《好家伙》（Goodfellas）和其他硬汉电影里的台词。在圣诞演讲中，他继续谴责了一堆被他清除的人，包括这些家伙。
Bob Nunamacher, who was a plumber in this department who thought he was better than the people he worked with, including me. He even attempted to fight my decision to get rid of him by going to our union officials at the local and the region. It took me one day to eliminate him and his partner who said to me he had an allegiance to him, not me. Two days later, they were both gone. Now, this was his holiday message.
“鲍勃·努纳马赫（Bob Nunamacher），这个部门的管道工，他觉得他比一起工作的人都优秀，包括我。他甚至试图去当地和地区的工会官员那里反抗我解雇他的决定。我花了一天时间就清除了他和他的搭档，那家伙竟然对我说他忠于那个人，而不是我。两天后，他们都走了。”现在，这就是他的假日祝词。
Sounds like a really fun party.
听起来是个真欢乐的聚会。
Oh, yeah. I think it probably upped the alcohol intake for the evening.
哦，是的。我想这可能增加了那晚的酒精摄入量。
The story of the plumbers was a classic case. There were two plumbers on staff. The senior plumber was giving Steve lip, but to get rid of him, Steve would have to get rid of the junior plumber first-- because of seniority rules. So he tried to get the junior plumber to take another position to make way for Steve to fire his partner. The guy didn't want to do it. One longtime employee who didn't want his name used told me about it. It disgusted him to see how easy it was for Steve to can the junior plumber.
管道工的故事是一个经典案例。员工里有两个管道工。高级管道工在跟史蒂夫顶嘴，但要除掉他，史蒂夫得先除掉初级管道工——因为资历规则。于是他试图让初级管道工去担任另一个职位，以便为解雇搭档腾出空间。那人不想这样做。一位不愿透露姓名的老员工告诉了我这件事。看到史蒂夫能如此轻易地解雇那个初级管道工，让他感到恶心。
So he got rid of him. Just that easy. And it was no challenge. There was no question, either from the administration, the school board, or anything. When it came across the table, there was just no questions. The union didn't question, this guy's got a year and a half. Why are you getting rid of him all of a sudden? Nothing.
所以他除掉了他。就是那么简单。这根本不是挑战。无论从管理层、学校董事会还是其他方面，根本没有任何疑问。当事情摆上台面时，根本没有人过问。工会也没有质疑：“这家伙都干了一年半了。为什么你突然要除掉他？”什么都没有。
Steve justified the firings as a cost-cutting measure to the administration, saying the district didn't need any plumbers. A month later, of course, they hired another plumber. But anyone who'd stuck up for the enemy plumbers was punished. This guy, who's retired now, had taken that risk, questioning the firings to Steve's face.
史蒂夫向管理层把解雇理由解释为削减成本，说学区不需要任何管道工。当然，一个月后，他们又雇了另一个管道工。但任何为这些倒霉的管道工出头的人都会受到惩罚。这个现在已经退休的家伙，当时冒着风险，当面质疑了这些解雇行为。
Well, I told him-- I said, I didn't think it was right.
嗯，我告诉他——我说，我觉得这不对。
And so after you said, I don't think it's the right thing, then what happened to you?
在你说了“我觉得这不对”之后，你遭遇了什么？
I went to the high school.
我被派去了高中。
And what did it mean to be sent over to the high school?
被派去高中意味着什么？
Well, it was just to humiliate the employee that was involved in that. You would have to take out the trash. You would get the worst part of the building to clean up after the kids. The one part of the building that was kind of isolated, where the milk was spilt, and the chips were thrown, and food was all over the windows and things. And there's nothing wrong with doing an honest day's work, but it wasn't-- I spent my whole life getting into this position. And now I'm demoted back to where I was 30 years ago.
嗯，这只是为了羞辱相关的员工。你得去倒垃圾。你得去清理楼里最糟糕的区域。那是楼里相对孤立的一部分，那里曾洒过牛奶，被扔过薯片，窗户上到处都是食物。做诚实的体力劳动没什么错，但这不是——我花了一辈子才坐到这个位置。而现在我被降职回到了30年前的水平。
So you were kind of exiled there.
所以你被流放到了那里。
Yes.
是的。
And how long did your exile last?
你的流放持续了多久？
Seven weeks. The length of time was until he felt you learned your lesson.
七周。持续时间取决于他认为你什么时候学到了教训。
Did you learn your lesson? In other words, did you speak up about things after that?
你学到教训了吗？换句话说，在那之后你还会对事情提出质疑吗？
No, I did not, because his big threat to me was that-- at the time, I was 51 years old. I had 30-plus years in the school district. Where was I going to go and get a job? What was I going to do, start over? How was I going to afford my child support? How was I going to support my children? How was I going to do things with my sons, that I enjoyed doing, without a job? And he used that.
不，我没有，因为他给我的最大威胁是——当时，我51岁了。我在学区工作了30多年。我能去哪里找工作？我能做什么，从头开始吗？我怎么负担得起我的赡养费？我怎么养活我的孩子？我怎么能在我没有工作的情况下和我喜欢的儿子们一起做那些事？他利用了这一点。
Wait. Are those things you were saying to yourself inside your head, or things he was saying to you?
等等。这些是你心里对自己说的话，还是他对你说的话？
No, he was saying that to me. Those were quotes.
不，那是他对我说的。那些是原话。
I heard this over and over. I needed my job. What choice did I have? I had no one to complain to. I had nowhere to go for help. Steve convinced his workers that he was responsible for any pleasure, any benefit that came their way, which meant he could also take it away without warning. it's the oldest trick in the tyrant playbook.
我一次又一次地听到这个。我需要这份工作。我有什么选择？我没有人可以投诉。我无处求助。史蒂夫让他的工人们相信，任何降临到他们头上的快乐、任何好处都归功于他，这意味着他也可以毫无预警地收回这些好处。这是暴君剧本里最古老的把戏。
Steve knew the only way he could maintain the kind of absolute control he wanted over the people below him was to be in the excellent good graces of the many bosses above him-- in the union, the school board, and the district administration. Arguably, his chief talent was figuring out how to make himself indispensable to them. Steve had worked in the school system so long, he knew exactly which levers to pull and in what order.
史蒂夫知道，要维持他对下属的绝对控制，唯一的办法就是获得他上方众多老板——工会、学校董事会和学区行政部门——的赏识。可以说，他最主要的才能就是弄清楚如何让自己变得不可或缺。史蒂夫在学校系统工作了太久，他确切地知道该拉动哪些杠杆，以及以什么顺序拉动。
He started with the union. In the 1990s, the district's maintenance department was in bad shape. It was unruly, and supervisors weren't lasting very long. The district was getting lots of grievances about working conditions and pay. It got so bad that the district considered getting rid of the maintenance department altogether, hiring an outside company to do the work. Back in those days, Steve Raucci was just a regular utility worker with a reputation for strangely aggressive pranks.
他从工会开始。20世纪90年代，学区的维修部门状况不佳。部门纪律涣散，主管也干不长。学区收到了大量关于工作条件和薪酬的申诉。情况变得如此糟糕，以至于学区考虑完全解散维修部门，聘请外部公司来做这份工作。在那个时候，史蒂夫·劳奇只是个普通的后勤工人，以奇怪的侵略性恶作剧而闻名。
He decided to run for president of his unit in the union, which is the CSEA-- Civil Service Employees Association. He promised to help settle the workers problems himself, and he won. John Lapointe, the electrician from the space heater incident, voted for Steve, even campaigned for him. John's a slim, dark-haired guy with a goatee and stylish glasses. He's in his 50s, and his son also works in the maintenance department. John's a deeply nice and gentle man. And yet, he became one of Steve's inner circle.
他决定竞选工会部门的主席，也就是CSEA（公务员雇员协会）。他承诺亲自解决工人的问题，结果他赢了。那个暖风机事件中的电工约翰·拉普安特投票给了史蒂夫，甚至为他助选。约翰是个留着山羊胡、戴着时尚眼镜的瘦高个子。他50多岁了，他的儿子也在维修部门工作。约翰是个非常善良且温柔的人。然而，他成了史蒂夫核心圈子的一员。
John and his wife would go to dinner with Steve and his wife and a few other couples. You couldn't refuse these dinners. At the time, 2001, John was impressed with Steve.
约翰和他的妻子会和史蒂夫夫妇以及其他几对夫妇一起吃饭。你无法拒绝这些晚餐。当时是2001年，约翰对史蒂夫印象深刻。
In the beginning he was very effective, jumping on issues immediately, resolving them immediately, and he seemed like, wow, this guy's a pit bull. You know what I mean? He's grabbing, growling, and getting stuff done.
起初他非常高效，立即处理问题，立即解决，他看起来像，哇，这哥们儿是个斗牛犬。你明白我的意思吗？他抓、吼，而且能把事情办成。
And you won't be surprised to learn that under his administration, the number of grievances from that unit went from an average of 20 to 25 a year down to zero.
你一定不会惊讶地发现，在他的管理下，该部门的申诉数量从平均每年20到25起降到了零。
That's Carl Strock again, the columnist.
那是卡尔·斯特罗克的评论。
There were no union grievances. So this, of course, is a big advantage to the administration. You know, it's time consuming to deal with these grievances. He was a wonderful asset.
没有工会申诉。所以，这当然对行政部门是个巨大优势。你知道，处理这些申诉很花时间。他是个极好的资产。
As head of the union, Steve had the opportunity to gain entrance to the inner workings of the entire school district, all from his perch in the maintenance office. He became friendly with a guy named Jeff Janiszewski. They had breakfast meetings at a local chain restaurant. Janiszewski was school board president. But even when he wasn't on the board, Janiszewski was widely known around town as the board's kingmaker. He chose candidates and got them elected. That's where Steve Raucci came in.
作为工会负责人，史蒂夫有机会进入整个学区的内部运作，所有这些都源于他在维修办公室的职位。他和一个叫杰夫·雅尼谢夫斯基（Jeff Janiszewski）的人成了朋友。他们会在当地的一家连锁餐厅开早餐会。雅尼谢夫斯基是学校董事会主席。但即使他不在董事会时，雅尼谢夫斯基在城里也被公认为是董事会的“造王者”。他选择候选人并让他们当选。这就是史蒂夫·劳奇发挥作用的地方。
Their whole electioneering effort was pretty much undertaken by the O&M unit.
他们的整个选举工作几乎都是由运营与维修（O&M）部门承担的。
That's DA Bob Carney. O and M is the operations and maintenance department, the one Raucci ran.
那是地区检察官鲍勃·卡尼。O&M就是劳奇运营的运营与维修部门。
If they had phone banks at night, he would bring 20 of his guys. The teachers would bring maybe two. They would pass out flyers. They would do phone banking of voters. And overwhelmingly, it was his people. I do believe, from what I know about electioneering, and politics, and the school board elections, that that kind of level of effort would be effective to turn an election because you're only dealing with 400 or 500 people that vote.
如果他们晚上有电话拉票，他会带上他的20个手下。老师们可能带两三个。他们会派发传单。他们会进行电话拉票。而绝大多数人都是他的人。根据我对选举、政治和学校董事会选举的了解，我相信这种程度的努力对于扭转选举结果是有效的，因为你面对的选民只有400到500人。
And for many years, that faction was very successful in controlling the school district, and consistently won school board elections. And Raucci took credit for that in memos and emails that he sent to them.
多年来，那个派系在控制学区方面非常成功，并一直赢得学校董事会选举。劳奇在发给他们的备忘录和电子邮件中将此归功于自己。
Several people who worked for Raucci told me if they refused to do all this campaign grunt work, they'd most certainly be punished for it. They also told me they'd had to pass out election flyers, endorsing candidates or urging passage of the budget, door-to-door on district time, which is illegal in New York.
几个为劳奇工作的人告诉我，如果他们拒绝做这些竞选苦力活，他们肯定会受到惩罚。他们还告诉我，他们必须在工作时间挨家挨户散发支持候选人或敦促通过预算的选举传单，这在纽约是非法的。
Steve's influence earned him yet more influence. Two years after becoming union president, he was promoted to director of buildings and grounds for the district. His salary jumped from $37,500 to $67,500. But he wasn't called the director, because if he officially became a director or manager of anything, that meant he couldn't also be in the union, much less run his unit, a position he very much wanted to keep.
史蒂夫的影响力让他获得了更多影响力。成为工会主席两年后，他被提升为学区建筑与场地主任。他的工资从37,500美元跃升至67,500美元。但他被称为“主任”并不是正式职衔，因为如果他正式成为任何东西的主管或经理，那就意味着他不能再留在工会，更不用说管理他的部门了，而这是一个他非常想保留的职位。
So on paper, he finagled the underwhelming title of, quote, "head utility worker." That way he could keep his union control. In addition, he wouldn't have to take the civil service exam required to qualify for a manager's job. And importantly, he could still get overtime pay, which managers don't. I asked a former district official, who didn't want to be named, about all this, why he allowed Raucci to cut all these corners in terms of his title and his pay, while he promoted him at all considering his history.
所以，在纸面上，他耍了个滑头，获得了令人不敢恭维的头衔，也就是所谓的“后勤主管”。这样他就可以保持对工会的控制。此外，他不需要参加经理职位所需的公务员考试。更重要的是，他仍然可以获得加班费，而经理是没有的。我问了一位不愿透露姓名的前学区官员，问他为什么允许劳奇在职位和薪水上耍这么多花招，而且考虑到他的过往记录，他为什么要提拔他。
In the past, Raucci had been disciplined for taking work trucks home or disappearing on the job, and there were rumors about explosives. An administrator's car had been set on fire, for instance, and there was talk that Raucci was involved. The former official sorrowfully defended his decisions. I believed in Steve Raucci, he told me. The maintenance department was a tough unit, a troubled unit, and I thought he was someone who cared about the district, who would do a good job. I'm sorry now. But it's hard to say publicly that I believed in him at the time. It's like saying you think Hitler was a good guy.
过去，劳奇曾因把工作卡车开回家或在工作中玩失踪而受到纪律处分，还有关于爆炸物的传言。例如，一名行政人员的汽车曾被纵火，有传言说劳奇参与其中。这位前官员悲伤地为自己的决定辩护。“我信任史蒂夫·劳奇，”他告诉我。“维修部门是一个艰难的部门，一个麻烦不断的部门，我以为他是一个关心学区、能做好工作的人。我现在很后悔。但很难公开说我当时信任他。这就像说你认为希特勒是个好人一样。”
As for the personnel file, the former official said he didn't know about all the complaints and suspicions about Steve at the time, because he never looked at the file.
至于人事档案，这位前官员说，当时他对史蒂夫的所有投诉和怀疑一无所知，因为他从没看过档案。
This part of Steve's story is the most confounding to me. How it could have happened that a boss of 110 people was also their union president, which in Steve's case meant he could threaten their jobs, prevent them from going over his head, cut off all avenues of complaint. How was such a blatant conflict of interest allowed to stand?
这部分史蒂夫的故事让我最费解。一个管理110人的老板怎么同时也是他们的工会主席？在史蒂夫的案例中，这意味着他可以威胁他们的工作，阻止他们越级上报，切断所有投诉渠道。这种明显的利益冲突怎么被允许存在？
Some people had brought it up, and it was squelched pretty quick. Steve dealt with that very quickly.
有些人提过，但很快就被压下去了。史蒂夫处理得非常快。
John Lapointe again.
又是约翰·拉普安特。
We actually had a meeting at CSEA headquarters in Latham, and it was explained to us that it was actually quite common for a boss to also be a union president.
我们实际上在莱瑟姆（Latham）的CSEA总部开过一次会，有人向我们解释说，老板同时也是工会主席其实很常见。
In fact, it's not that strange for a so-called straw boss to be a union president-- someone who's supervising maybe four or five people. What is unheard of at CSEA, however, and probably at any union, is a union president who's an actual boss over 110 people, capable of hiring and firing at will. It seems only a couple of people tried to do anything about this. One of them was Michelle Tabbano, co-chair of the union's grievance committee for Schenectady County. She tried hard to boot him, but she was blocked at every turn.
事实上，所谓的“稻草人老板”担任工会主席并不奇怪——那种可能只监管四五个人的老板。然而，在CSEA，或者任何工会，从未听说过一个工会主席竟然是管理110人、能够随意雇佣和解雇员工的老板。似乎只有几个人试图对此采取行动。其中之一是米歇尔·塔巴诺（Michelle Tabbano），斯克内克塔迪县工会申诉委员会的联合主席。她努力想把他踢出去，但每一步都被阻挠。
I was part of three meetings trying to get Steve Raucci out. I knew that, with the position he was in, was a conflict of interest, and that he should have had judicial charges filed against him. I knew that. So I had a meeting with Kathy Garrison.
我参加了三次试图把史蒂夫·劳奇弄走的会议。我知道，以他所处的职位，存在利益冲突，应该对他提起司法诉讼。我明白这点。所以我找凯西·加里森（Kathy Garrison）开了一次会。
Kathy Garrison is the region four president of CSEA.
凯西·加里森是CSEA第四区的负责人。
I know Steve Raucci was there, and I told him I wanted him out of the union. I thought we had all evidence in the world to prove that he was part of management. What more egregious thing can you have, is the union present to be in bed with the school board, with the facilities supervisor, with the attorneys? Are you kidding me? That's who represents our members? Just one of those things he should have been-- you're working me all up. [LAUGHS] I'm sorry.
我知道史蒂夫·劳奇也在场，我告诉他我想要他离开工会。我认为我们有全世界所有的证据来证明他是管理层的一部分。还有什么比让工会主席与学校董事会、设施主管、律师勾结更恶劣的事呢？你在开玩笑吗？这就是代表我们成员的人？这就是那种他应该被——你把我气得……抱歉。[笑]
Tabbano took up this fight when she started getting phone calls. Two, three, then six, maybe eight total-- people who worked for Steve.
塔巴诺是在开始接到电话后才开始这场斗争的。两个、三个，然后六个，总共可能八个——都是在史蒂夫手下工作的人。
And it was always the same complaint-- bullying, belittling people, embarrassing people, threatening to fire them if they didn't do what he said. And I told them that we could file grievances, but I needed them to give me their name and we could talk about it, so-- but nobody ever would. And then I wouldn't hear from them again. They said they were afraid of the repercussions.
抱怨的内容总是如出一辙——霸凌、贬低他人、羞辱他人、威胁如果不听话就解雇他们。我告诉他们，我们可以提出申诉，但我需要他们提供名字，我们可以谈谈，所以……但从来没人愿意。然后我就再也没收到他们的消息。他们说他们害怕后果。
The reason they were calling her is because they couldn't use the normal chain of command. If a worker had a problem, they were first supposed to go to their supervisor, Steve. Then their complaint went go up a level to the district's director of human resources, Mike Stricos, a pal of Steve's who once presented him with a framed picture of Marlon Brando as the Godfather at a morning staff meeting. After that, there was the union's labor relations specialist, a guy named Mike Campon, who was good friends with school board president Jeff Janiszewski, another Steve supporter.
他们打电话给她的原因是他们无法使用正常的指挥链。如果工人有困难，他们首先应该去找他们的主管，史蒂夫。然后他们的投诉会向上升一级，到学区的人力资源总监迈克·斯特里科斯（Mike Stricos）那里——他是史蒂夫的铁哥们，曾在一次早会上送给史蒂夫一幅装裱好的马龙·白兰度在《教父》中的照片。在那之后，还有工会的劳动关系专家，一个叫迈克·坎彭（Mike Campon）的家伙，他是学校董事会主席杰夫·雅尼谢夫斯基的好朋友，后者是史蒂夫的另一个支持者。
And the head of the union local? Also friends with Steve. It was a spider's web of good old boys. Since Tabbano couldn't get workers to go public, she tried to oust Steve on a technicality. He was clearly making too much money for his title of head utility worker, which therefore had to be a phony. She filed official requests, twice, with the school district demanding that they disclose financial information about Steve. And how did the school district respond to these official requests for transparency regarding Steve's position? Request they're required to respond to, according to labor law?
工会分部负责人呢？也是史蒂夫的朋友。这是一个“老男孩俱乐部”的蜘蛛网。由于塔巴诺无法让工人们公开站出来，她试图通过程序漏洞罢免史蒂夫。作为一个“后勤主管”，他的工资显然太高了，这必然是伪造的。她两次向学区正式提出要求，要求披露关于史蒂夫的财务信息。学区对这些关于史蒂夫职位的官方透明度要求是如何回应的？根据劳动法，他们必须回应这些要求。
They never answered me. They never answered me.
他们从没回复我。他们从没回复我。
Tabbano couldn't prove anything. And none of her union superiors cared to press it. The higher ups at CSEA liked Steve. He helped them with their campaigns.
塔巴诺没能证明任何事。她的工会上级也不在乎推动这件事。CSEA的高层喜欢史蒂夫。他帮他们助选。
You know, the union, I think, broke down at every level. I blame myself for a lot of these things. I wish I could've fought more to get him out of there. CSEA blew this one, big time. We blew it.
你知道，我认为工会在各个层面上都崩溃了。我为很多事情责怪自己。我希望我能争取更多机会把他赶走。CSEA在这件事上搞砸了，而且是大错特错。我们搞砸了。
One of the main ways Steve ingratiated himself with his bosses was also the most traditional, one used by any manager in any workplace to get in good with the people in charge. He saved them money-- lots of it. And the way he did that was pretty ingenious. In 2004, a year after he takes over the maintenance department, Steve also becomes the de facto energy manager for the district, hence the space heater incident.
史蒂夫讨好老板的主要方式也是最传统的一种，任何职场经理为了获得上级赏识都会用这一招。他为他们省了钱——省了很多。而他这么做的方式相当巧妙。2004年，在他接管维修部门一年后，史蒂夫也成了学区的“事实能源经理”，这就是暖风机事件的由来。
Another guy had had the job, but he wasn't meeting his energy reduction goals. What happened was that the district had invested in energy-tracking software that, if used properly, was supposed to reduce its energy consumption by, say, 20%, a big savings. A guy named Lou Semione was put in charge of the program, a seventy-something thousand dollar a year job. Steve decided he wanted it, so he began to sabotage Lou. John Lapointe knew what was going on.
另一个人曾做过这份工作，但他没能达到节能目标。发生的情况是，学区投资了能源追踪软件，如果使用得当，理论上可以减少约20%的能源消耗，这是一笔巨大的节省。一个叫卢·塞米奥尼（Lou Semione）的人被任命负责这个项目，这是一份年薪七万多美元的工作。史蒂夫决定他想要这份工作，于是他开始破坏卢。约翰·拉普安特知道发生了什么。
Steve would make it very difficult for Lou to have any access on the computer, to make any changes to the heating system, lighting, and so on.
史蒂夫会给卢设置重重困难，让他难以访问电脑，无法对供暖系统、照明等进行任何更改。
So wait. So Lou's in charge of getting the numbers down, but he doesn't actually have his hands on the buttons to make that happen?
等等。所以卢负责降低数据，但他实际上没有控制按钮来落实这些改变？
You got it. Right. There's a computer that you access, and you could see all the buildings through it, and make your changes. And Steve would let Lou see it, but not change anything. Somebody else would make the changes. So you can kind of take it from there what kind of changes were being made, and it wasn't in Lou's favor. OK?
你说对了。是的。有一台电脑你可以访问，通过它你可以看到所有的建筑物，并进行更改。史蒂夫会允许卢看它，但不允许更改任何东西。其他人会进行更改。所以你可以从中看出做了什么样的更改，而且这显然对卢不利。好吗？
Steve, for instance, left the heat and lights on in every building over the three-day Columbus Day holiday. He once pretended the school's football lights were broken, and John had to pretend to fix them.
例如，史蒂夫在哥伦布日的那个三天假期里，让每栋楼的暖气和灯都开着。他曾经假装学校的足球场灯坏了，约翰不得不假装去修它们。
These football field lights-- there's, god, I'm thinking about 120 of these lights. And they'd draw a lot of power. So we had them turned on during the day, and they stayed on for a few hours to eat up some energy. And in fact, they weren't being worked on. They were just being left on. And--
这些足球场灯——天哪，我记得有120盏灯。它们非常耗电。所以我们白天把它们打开，让它们开着几个小时来耗掉一些能源。事实上，它们并没有在维修。它们只是被开着。而且——
And did you know why?
你知道为什么吗？
Well, yeah. I mean, Steve didn't really hide the fact that he was screwing with Lou. You know what I mean?
嗯，是的。我是说，史蒂夫并没有真的隐瞒他在整卢的事实。你明白我的意思吗？
You knew what he was doing.
你知道他在干什么。
Well, how did you feel that he was asking you to do this thing, which you knew was totally baloney, and also unfair to this other guy?
嗯，当你被要求做这件事时，你是什么感觉？你知道这完全是胡扯，而且对另一个家伙也不公平。
Again, you just did what the guy wanted you to do.
再一次，你只是做了这人想让你做的事。
Did it make you mad?
这让你生气吗？
Well, of course. Well, you know--
嗯，当然。嗯，你知道——
It's upsetting.
这令人沮丧。
It is upsetting that you're doing this type of stuff. But again, I keep telling myself, I'm just doing what my boss asked me to do. He's your union president, your boss. With Steve, again, you're either with him or you're against him. That's the way it was.
做这种事确实令人沮丧。但再说一次，我不断告诉自己，我只是在做我老板要求我做的事。他是你的工会主席，你的老板。对于史蒂夫，再一次，你要么支持他，要么反对他。就是这样。
So Lou's energy savings numbers were bad, maybe single digits. Steve persuaded the administration to give him the job, instead. But again, not the title of energy manager, since that would jeopardize his union situation. He said he'd do the job for half Lou's salary, which he'd collect in overtime. In this way, Steve's salary nearly doubled, so that by the time he was arrested in 2009, he was making about $125,000 a year. The superintendent, by contrast, was making about $194,000.
所以卢的节能数据很差，可能只有个位数。史蒂夫说服管理层把工作交给他，而不是卢。但同样，没有“能源经理”的头衔，因为那会危及他的工会地位。他说他愿意以卢一半的薪水做这份工作，但他会通过加班费赚回来。这样一来，史蒂夫的薪水几乎翻了一番，以至于到2009年他被捕时，他一年赚大约125,000美元。相比之下，负责的学区督导年薪约194,000美元。
As energy czar, Steve was fearless. He would openly do battle with anyone who tried to turn on a switch he didn't think needed turning on. Didn't matter if you were a teacher, or an administrator, or one time a priest who wanted weekend heat in a classroom being leased from a church. In an email, Steve called the clergyman a, quote, "joker and a crook with a collar," and vowed to fight him.
作为能源沙皇，史蒂夫无所畏惧。他会公开与任何试图打开他认为不需要打开的开关的人作战。不管你是老师、行政人员，还是曾经有个牧师想在从教堂租赁的一间教室里周末供暖。在一封电子邮件中，史蒂夫称这位牧师为“戴着领子的笑话和骗子”，并誓言要与他斗争。
Because of all this, Steve's energy reduction numbers were great. He got consumption down by a stunning 30%, saved the district millions in bills, and was publicly praised by the administration. And in particular, by superintendent Eric Ely, for whom Raucci had a soft spot. Judging from their email exchanges, the two became pretty cozy.
正因为这一切，史蒂夫的节能数据非常漂亮。他将消耗量降低了惊人的30%，为学区节省了数百万美元的账单，并受到了管理层的公开赞扬。特别是受到督导埃里克·伊利（Eric Ely）的表扬，劳奇对他情有独钟。从他们的邮件往来判断，两人的关系相当亲密。
It's an email from Raucci to Eric Ely, superintendent of schools, dated September 4, 2008.
这是一封劳奇发给学校督导埃里克·伊利的邮件，日期是2008年9月4日。
That's DA Bob Carney.
这是地区检察官鲍勃·卡尼。
I've often told you that you and I are alike in many ways. We just have different backgrounds. We both like to win, and we do not care how we do it, as long as we win. We both tell it like it is, and if someone doesn't like what we say, that's too damn bad.
“我经常告诉你，你和我有很多相似之处。我们只是背景不同。我们都喜欢赢，而且我们不在乎怎么赢，只要赢了就行。我们都实话实说，如果有人不喜欢我们说的话，那真是太糟糕了。”
If we do not like someone, we let them know about it and usually do something about it. There we may differ a little. According to rumors, when I don't like someone, I force them to go away or make them disappear. When you don't like someone, you have to wait until they die of old age, unless you give me their name.
“如果我们不喜欢某人，我们会让他们知道，通常会采取行动。这一点上我们可能有点不同。据传闻，当我不喜欢某人时，我会迫使他们离开或让他们消失。当你不喜欢某人时，你得等他们老死，除非你告诉我他们的名字。”
The columnist Carl Strock has a favorite from these emails.
专栏作家卡尔·斯特罗克有这些邮件中最喜欢的一封。
Here's one from the superintendent, Eric Ely, to Steve Raucci, dated February 16, 2009, which was just a couple of days before Raucci was arrested. When he had done everything he was going to do-- he had committed all his crimes, and all the complaints that were going to go to Ely had gone to him. He had been told. And Raucci had written him a sort of a flattering email. And Eric Ely responded, there aren't many I trust. You are one. Thank you, Eric.
这是一封督导埃里克·伊利发给史蒂夫·劳奇的邮件，日期是2009年2月16日，就在劳奇被捕的前几天。那时他已经做完了他要做的所有事——他犯下了所有罪行，所有本该传到伊利那里的投诉也都已经传过去了。他已经得到了通知。而劳奇发给他一封类似奉承的邮件。埃里克·伊利回应道：“我不信任的人不多。你是其中之一。谢谢你，埃里克。”
And then came the incident known simply as the letter, which eventually would lead to Steve's downfall.
接着发生了被称为“那封信”的事件，这最终导致了史蒂夫的倒台。
More on that in a minute. Steve Raucci finally goes too far, but he can't be brought down until his fork is stolen from a diner. Sarah Koenig's story about him continues, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
一会儿再说这个。史蒂夫·劳奇终于走得太远了，但在他的叉子在餐厅被偷走之前，他无法被击倒。莎拉·科尼格关于他的故事继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, today we're devoting our entire hour to the rise and fall of a petty tyrant, Steve Raucci, who inspired fear, who did what he wanted, who was untouchable in his job running the maintenance department for the Schenectady Public Schools. We first ran today's show back in 2010, shortly after all this happened.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚收听，今天我们整整一小时都在讲述一个小暴君史蒂夫·劳奇的兴衰，他激起恐惧，为所欲为，在管理斯克内克塔迪公立学校维修部门的工作中不可一世。我们第一次播出今天的节目是在2010年，这一切发生后不久。
We have arrived at the fall part of his rise and fall. Sarah Koenig picks up the story.
我们已经讲到了他兴衰史中的“衰”部分。莎拉·科尼格接着讲述这个故事。
In early 2005, someone sent an anonymous letter to the union's regional CSEA president, Kathy Garrison, complaining about Steve, saying he was running his unit like a mafia boss, but he wasn't qualified for his job, that he should be kicked out of CSEA. The letter immediately got back to Steve. John Lapointe again.
2005年初，有人给工会的地区CSEA主席凯西·加里森寄了一封匿名信，投诉史蒂夫，说他把部门运营得像黑帮一样，但他根本不称职，应该被踢出CSEA。这封信立刻传回到了史蒂夫那里。又是约翰·拉普安特。
He'd called me off a job and had me come into his office, quite agitated. And he's shoving this letter at me. And he's saying, read it, read it. And it was unbelievable. I mean, he was out of control, he was so angry. And we're trying to calm him down. And spit's flying out of his mouth. His veins were bulging out of his neck.
他把我从工作中叫走，让我去他的办公室，情绪非常激动。他把这封信推到我面前，说：“读，读啊。”这简直不可思议。我是说，他失控了，他太生气了。我们试图让他冷静下来。唾沫星子从他嘴里喷出来。脖子上的青筋突了出来。
His head looked like it was going to pop off his shoulders. This is how to heart he took this letter. I just started reading. Getting halfway through it, he's pressuring me. Who wrote this? You know who wrote this. And finally, I blurted out, Debbie?
他的头看起来快要从肩膀上掉下来了。这就是他把这封信看得有多重。我开始读。读到一半时，他向我施压。“谁写的？你知道是谁写的。”最后，我脱口而出：“黛比？”
Debbie was Debbie Gray, wife of Hal Gray, who worked in the maintenance department alongside John Lapointe. Hal had gone to high school with Steve, had known him forever. And Hal and Debbie were both active in the union. And for the record, Debbie says she didn't write that notorious letter, that she's not the type to do anything like that anonymously. But Steve was convinced. He and Hal hadn't been getting along. Steve confronted Hal about the letter, called him a rat, forbid him to come to morning meetings, banished him to the high school.
黛比是黛比·格雷（Debbie Gray），她是和约翰·拉普安特一起在维修部门工作的哈尔·格雷（Hal Gray）的妻子。哈尔和史蒂夫是高中同学，从小就认识。哈尔和黛比都是工会的积极分子。顺便说一句，黛比说她没写那封臭名昭著的信，她说她不是那种会匿名做这种事的人。但史蒂夫认定是她。他和哈尔的关系一直不好。史蒂夫找哈尔对质这封信，叫他“内奸”，禁止他参加早会，并把他流放到高中。
A few months later, in May of 2005, the Grays discovered rat spray painted in huge capital letters across their tan suburban two-story house. Steve arranged a caravan from work to go check it out. He made all the guys pile into four district vehicles and drive about 10 miles away to the town of Burnt Hills where the grays lived.
几个月后的2005年5月，格雷夫妇发现他们那栋浅黄色的郊区两层别墅上被用巨大的大写字母喷漆写着“内奸”。史蒂夫组织了一个车队从工作地点出发去现场查看。他让所有人都挤进四辆学区车里，开车去了约10英里外格雷夫妇居住的伯恩特山（Burnt Hills）镇。
We saw the side of the house, the front of the house, and then the other side as you go past it-- rat in I believe it was red paint. The vehicles were splashed in paint, the front door. This house was devastated.
我们看到了房子的侧面、正面，当你经过时看到另一面——我记得是用红色油漆写的“内奸”。车上溅满了油漆，前门也是。这栋房子被毁了。
John Lapointe was in the passenger seat in the lead car next to Steve.
约翰·拉普安特坐在史蒂夫旁边的头车副驾驶座上。
He was very amused on the way up and on the way back, and you had to put on the face, too. You're riding in the vehicle with him. You have to show him the approval, so to speak. He wanted to see you happy about this because he was reveling in the glory of what he--
他在去的路上和回来的路上都觉得很好玩，你也得配合露出表情。你和他坐在车里。你必须向他展示认可。他想看你对此感到高兴，因为他正在沉浸在他——
Had supposedly done.
所谓的成就感中。
--supposedly had done.
——所谓的成就中。
I saw pictures of the damage. Steve's MO with paint was to hit every surface, every fixture, every window to make it really expensive to fix. He was a professional, after all. There were more attacks of vandalism on the Grays over the years, maybe six altogether. And threats to burn down their house, to move out of town, or else. They complained to the union about it. School district officials knew about it. But there was no evidence linking Raucci to the crimes. Nothing happened.
我看了损毁的照片。史蒂夫用油漆的套路是打击每一个表面、每一个固定装置、每一扇窗户，让维修变得非常昂贵。毕竟他是个专业人士。多年来，针对格雷夫妇的破坏行为还有更多，总共可能六起。还有烧毁他们房子、让他们搬出镇子否则后果自负的威胁。他们向工会投诉了此事。学区官员也知道了。但没有任何证据将劳奇与这些犯罪联系起来。什么都没发生。
Finally, after 2 and 1/2 years, Hal and Debbie Gray called the district attorney's office in Schenectady. DA Bob Carney didn't think much would come of it.
最终，两年半后，哈尔和黛比·格雷打电话给斯克内克塔迪地区检察官办公室。地区检察官鲍勃·卡尼没觉得会有什么结果。
My secretary scheduled a meeting for me with some people from the local CSEA. They wanted to talk to me about a problem they were having in the union. So I assumed it was something to do with control of the union, or union infighting. And I wasn't expecting what I got.
我的秘书为我和一些当地CSEA的人安排了一次会议。他们想和我谈谈工会里遇到的问题。所以我以为这和控制工会或工会内部斗争有关。我没料到会得到那样的结果。
Carney had never heard of Steve Raucci. He says he was blown away by their story.
卡尼以前从没听说过史蒂夫·劳奇。他说他们的故事让他大开眼界。
They were very angry, and they were very scared. Hal Gray was a decorated helicopter pilot from Vietnam. He's a very tough guy. But the fact that their home was under attack in the middle of the night, and it's one thing to say, in hindsight, well, it was spray paint. You can deal with spray paint. But the problem is, you don't know what you have to deal with. And if somebody is capable of spray painting your house, he's also capable of setting it on fire.
他们非常生气，也非常害怕。哈尔·格雷是一名曾参加越南战争的功勋直升机飞行员。他是个硬汉。但事实是，他们的家在深夜遭到攻击，事后看来，说“好吧，这只是喷漆，可以处理”是一回事。但问题在于，你不知道你必须面对的是什么。如果有人有能力向你的房子喷漆，他也有能力放火烧掉它。
And so they lived in fear that their house, their property, and maybe their lives would be in danger at any time. I know he told me that they ended up secreting arms around the house-- rifles, guns-- to protect themselves in case they needed it. And at that point, they also told me about other victims that Raucci had accrued over the years. And so we start to make inquiries and got some police agencies involved.
所以他们生活在恐惧中，担心他们的房子、财产，甚至生命随时会受到威胁。我知道他告诉我，他们最终在房子周围私藏了武器——步枪、枪支——以备不时之需。在那一点上，他们还告诉了我劳奇多年来积攒的其他受害者。于是我们开始调查，并让警察部门介入。
Turns out Raucci was suspected in all kinds of other stuff, dangerous stuff. The case of Gary DiNola, for instance. DiNola was the district's well-respected athletics director and an award-winning teacher. He fought with Steve for a year and a half about getting access to sports facilities, which Steve denied him. So finally, DiNola complained to superintendent Eric Ely. Steve instantly found out, and sent DiNola a menacing email. DiNola woke up the next morning to find his tires slashed and an explosive-- a big one-- tucked under his windshield wiper.
事实证明，劳奇还涉嫌各种其他事情，危险的事情。以加里·迪诺拉（Gary DiNola）的案件为例。迪诺拉是学区受人尊敬的体育总监和获奖教师。他和史蒂夫为了获取体育设施的使用权斗争了一年半，史蒂夫拒绝了他。最终，迪诺拉向督导埃里克·伊利投诉。史蒂夫立刻发现了，并发给迪诺拉一封威胁邮件。迪诺拉第二天早上醒来，发现轮胎被扎破了，雨刷下塞着一枚爆炸装置——一个大家伙。
There were old cases, too. The most serious was from 2001 in the nearby town of Rotterdam, when a man was woken up in the middle of the night to his metal front door being blown in by a bomb. Steve got the wrong address in that case. The bomb had been meant for a cop down the street.
也有旧案。最严重的是2001年在附近的鹿特丹镇，一名男子在半夜被炸弹炸开金属前门惊醒。史蒂夫在那起案件中弄错了地址。那枚炸弹本是给街对面的一名警察准备的。
And there was the case of Laura Balogh. Laura worked at the union and had been romantically involved with the union's local president. When the relationship broke up, Steve went to her house at night, spray painted "cheater" in red letters on her house in Schodack, and planted an explosive on her doorstep, which never detonated.
还有劳拉·巴洛（Laura Balogh）的案子。劳拉在工会工作，曾与工会地方主席有过恋爱关系。当两人分手后，史蒂夫晚上去了她家，在斯克达克的房子上用红漆喷上“骗子”，并在她门口安装了一个爆炸装置，但从未引爆。
That was investigators' first big break. Raucci had used a cigarette butt as a fuse in the homemade bomb. But Raucci wasn't a smoker, and he didn't know about New York's safety paper regulations, that a butt will go out on its own if it's left lit. From the stub, the police got a DNA sample. But since Raucci had no criminal record, he wasn't in their system. They couldn't make a match until they got another sample they knew to be from Raucci. Ellen Frederick, Raucci's former secretary, is married to a former cop. And that former cop knew the state police investigator in charge of Raucci's case.
那是调查人员的第一个重大突破。劳奇在自制炸弹中用了烟头作为引信。但劳奇不抽烟，他不知道纽约的安全纸张法规，烟头如果点燃后放着，会自动熄灭。调查人员从烟蒂上提取到了DNA样本。但因为劳奇没有犯罪记录，他不在系统里。他们无法匹配，直到他们得到了另一个他们确定是劳奇的样本。史蒂夫的前秘书艾伦·弗雷德里克嫁给了一名前警察。那名前警察认识负责劳奇案件的州警调查员。
This investigator approached my husband at a gathering and said, you know, I understand that your wife knows quite a bit about this Steve Raucci. And my husband said, yeah, she does. I mean, she was his secretary, whatever. And he said, I'd really like to sit and talk with her. Well, and that got the ball rolling.
这位调查员在聚会上走近我丈夫说：“你知道，我听说你妻子对这个史蒂夫·劳奇了解不少。”我丈夫说：“是的，确实。”我是说，她是他的秘书什么的。他说：“我真的很想和她坐下来谈谈。”嗯，这让事情开始运转了。
They came up with a plan. Steve ate breakfast out at local diners-- Sally's, Peter Pause, Blue Ribbon. Ellen would discreetly find out from one of her old colleagues where Steve was headed that morning, and then tell the investigator where to go. The investigator would try to secure a dirty utensil from Steve's place setting. After weeks of trying, the investigator finally nabbed a fork off Steve's plate before the waitress could clear it away. The cops had their match. They had enough evidence to link Steve to the crimes at Laura Balogh's house.
他们想出了一个计划。史蒂夫常在当地餐馆吃早餐——莎莉餐厅、彼得暂停餐厅、蓝丝带餐厅。艾伦会从以前的同事那里不动声色地打听到史蒂夫那天早上要去哪儿，然后告诉调查员去哪里。调查员会设法弄到史蒂夫餐位上的脏餐具。尝试了几周后，调查员终于在服务员清理盘子前从史蒂夫的盘子里拿走了一个叉子。警察有了匹配结果。他们有足够的证据将史蒂夫与劳拉·巴洛家发生的犯罪联系起来。
And they could have stopped there, but they wanted to try to get him for the other crimes, too. So they enlisted Keith McKenna, another former cop, who'd recently been busted on a drug charge and was in trouble. Many years before, Keith and Steve had been close friends. They palled around after hours, messed with explosives together. As it happened, DA Bob Carney had grown up across the street from Keith McKenna, and suggested he might help out with the case. Keith hadn't spent time with Steve for a decade, but he goes to see him at the school on the pretense of needing help, some kind of job. Steve is warm and welcoming, and remarkably forthcoming.
他们本来可以就此收手，但他们想尝试把他抓起来为其他罪行负责。于是他们争取到了基思·麦肯纳（Keith McKenna）的帮助，他也是一名前警察，最近因毒品指控被抓，正处于麻烦中。多年前，基思和史蒂夫曾是密友。他们下班后一起混，一起玩爆炸物。碰巧，地区检察官鲍勃·卡尼是在基思·麦肯纳对面长大的，建议他可以帮忙处理这个案子。基思已经十年没和史蒂夫往来了，但他借口需要帮助或找工作去学校找他。史蒂夫热情好客，而且出奇地健谈。
When I talk, Keith, anything I say, I could say in a court of law. I never say, yeah, I blew up a window. No, I just-- you never know if somebody's wired or that type of thing.
“我说话的时候，基思，我说的一切，我都能在法庭上说。我从不说：‘是的，我炸了一个窗户。’不，我只是——你永远不知道某人是否戴着窃听器之类的东西。”
Of course, what Steve doesn't know is that Keith is wired. I wrote to Steve Raucci in prison asking for an interview, but never heard back. So these tapes are all we've got. Listening to them, it's like hearing a grainy, homemade version of those mobster movies Steve likes so much. Steve talks about punks, and broads, and wiseguys, and street justice.
当然，史蒂夫不知道的是，基思戴着窃听器。我给监狱里的史蒂夫·劳奇写信要求采访，但没得到回应。所以这些录音是我们仅有的资料。听着这些录音，就像在听史蒂夫喜欢的那些黑帮电影的粗糙自制版。史蒂夫谈论混混、娘们儿、聪明的家伙和街头正义。
I still don't like punks. I don't like wiseguys, and I still believe in people should get what they deserve.
“我依然不喜欢混混。我不喜欢聪明的家伙，而且我依然认为人们应该得到他们应得的。”
It's almost as if Steve's been waiting all his life to lay out his world view on tape, if only someone would ask. Keith McKenna doesn't even have to. He says relatively little in these recordings, which are from three separate meetings in Steve's office over the course of two months. In answer to the most generic questions-- what have you been up to lately? How's work? Have you seen so-and-so-- Steve lets loose like a champion.
这几乎就像史蒂夫一生都在等待在磁带上阐明他的世界观，只要有人问就行。基思·麦肯纳甚至不需要问。他在这些录音中说得很少，这些录音来自两个月内史蒂夫办公室里的三次独立会面。回答最普通的问题——“最近忙什么？”“工作怎么样？”“见到某某了吗”——史蒂夫就像个冠军一样滔滔不绝。
For the cops, the tapes are a goldmine. Steve essentially confesses by name to almost all of the bombings, and vandalism, and bad acts the cops already suspect him of-- Hal and Debbie Gray, the 2001 Rotterdam bombing, how he didn't know the cigarette butts wouldn't light his explosives.
对于警察来说，这些磁带是金矿。史蒂夫基本上用名字供认了警察已经怀疑他的几乎所有爆炸案、破坏行为和恶行——哈尔和黛比·格雷案、2001年鹿特丹爆炸案，以及他如何不知道烟蒂点不着他的爆炸装置。
I just wondered why the last two never went off, but no, how would I know?
“我只是想知道为什么最后两次都没引爆，但是，我怎么会知道呢？”
And why taking revenge on someone at home is his method of choice.
以及为什么在家中对他人的报复是他偏爱的方法。
Probably one of the worst things that somebody could think of is not feeling safe in your own house, OK? So I guess where I'm going with this, Keith, is that some of the things I do-- like, I never want to physically hurt anyone. Property damage-- you can do a lot with that.
“一个人能想到的最糟糕的事情之一可能就是在家中没有安全感，好吗？所以我猜我想要表达的是，基思，我做的一些事情——比如，我从不想造成身体伤害。财产损失——你可以通过这个做很多事。”
"Property damage-- you can do a lot with that." A big theme with Steve in these recordings is how there's nothing he can't get away with in the district. Nobody dares tell him to make cuts in his department. He can hire who he likes, fire who he likes. No one can complain.
“财产损失——你可以通过这个做很多事。”史蒂夫在这些录音中的一个大主题是他如何在学区内无所不能。没人敢告诉他要在部门里裁员。他可以雇他喜欢的人，解雇他喜欢的人。没人能抱怨。
They're not going to file a grievance against me, not if they want to last, or live, one or the other.
“他们不会对我提出申诉，如果他们想维持现状，或者活着——二者必选其一。”
Then he gestures to the photo of the Godfather, Don Corleone, that's hanging on his wall.
然后他指了指挂在墙上的那张《教父》堂·柯里昂的照片。
The reason I keep that picture behind the door is that was given to me by the people up there in the administration office--
“我把那张照片挂在门后的原因是，那是行政办公室那边的人给我的——”
Oh, OK.
“哦，好的。”
Because that's the way they see me. Don Raucci, and I never even saw that whole series. I'm everybody's hero, and they know it. I think they, in a way, admire that about me when I talk about, sometimes, that's the only justice there is, street justice. And I always tell them-- I'll say to Eric or the board-- you guys are [BLEEP] lucky. You got a Steve. When it falls on me, I don't have a Steve to go to. I got to fix it.
“因为他们就是这样看我的。堂·劳奇，而我甚至没看过整个系列。我是每个人的英雄，他们知道这一点。我觉得某种程度上，当我谈到有时这是唯一正义——街头正义时，他们对此很钦佩。我总是告诉他们——我会对埃里克或董事会说——你们这些家伙真是该死的幸运。你们有个史蒂夫。当我遇到困难时，我没有史蒂夫可以找。我得自己解决。”
I'll be a legend here in their eyes. When I'm dead and gone, they'll always be talking about what Steve did, and what he could do, and that type of thing. In just the sticks alone, I said two weeks ago, I can't believe how much you guys have come to depend on me. The [BLEEP]? You know, what are you going to do if I'm not around? Because the superintendent-- he's certainly never going to tell me what to do. He listens to me. If I tell him this is what you should do, that's what he'll do. I mean, that's how far it's come. The board president, Jeff-- nobody here can handle the union aspect. Nobody can--
“在他们眼中我将是个传奇。当我死了走了，他们总会谈论史蒂夫做了什么，他能做什么，诸如此类的事。仅仅是棍棒本身，我说过两周前，我无法相信你们这些家伙变得有多依赖我。该死？你知道，如果我不在了，你们打算怎么办？因为督导——他当然永远不会告诉我该做什么。他听我的。如果我告诉他这是你应该做的，他就会照做。我是说，事情发展到这一步了。董事会主席，杰夫——这里没人能处理工会方面的事。没人能……”
You're not in the union, though, right?
“你不是在工会里，对吧？”
Yeah.
“是的。”
You are?
“你是吗？”
Yeah. That's what I'm saying. There's nothing I can't do. Yeah, I'm still president of my union.
“是的。这就是我想说的。没什么是我做不到的。是的，我依然是我的工会主席。”
How?
“怎么做到的？”
Because I can. That's all I can tell you. Don't ask me how, Keith. Because I can.
“因为我能。我只能告诉你这些。别问我怎么做到的，基思。因为我能。”
What's striking about these tapes is that Steve sees himself on the side of good. He only does bad things to bullies, he says. He hates bullies. Any anyway, most of what he does-- like planting a bomb at the house of Laura Balogh, the one who broke up with his local union president-- are on behalf of friends, against people he doesn't even know. He'll do anything for a friend, he says. He's loyal that way. Even the guys who work for him-- he says he lies for them all the time, lets them leave early or bill for overtime they don't deserve.
这些磁带最引人注目的是，史蒂夫认为自己站在正义的一边。他说，他只对恶霸做坏事。他讨厌恶霸。而且无论如何，他做的大部分事情——比如在劳拉·巴洛家安装炸弹，那个和他工会地方主席分手的人——都是为了朋友，针对那些他甚至不认识的人。他说，他会为朋友做任何事。他那方面很讲义气。甚至那些为他工作的人——他说他总是为他们撒谎，让他们早退或者申报他们不应得的加班费。
But I take care of them. I've had guys that have gone out for three months, no sick time, keep them on the books. Keith, I could go to jail for the things I do, and I don't benefit one bit for me. "Monetarial" or finance, I benefit at no way whatsoever.
“但我照顾他们。我有些家伙三个月没上班，没有病假，我还是把他们留在名册上。基思，我可以因为我做的这些事坐牢，但我一点好处也没捞到。‘金钱上’或财务上，我没有任何收益。”
And still, they don't love him enough for it. He complains to Keith that he doesn't have any real friends at work.
尽管如此，他们对他还不够爱。他向基思抱怨说，他在工作里没有真正的朋友。
If I left this place tomorrow, there ain't a soul here that would dial my phone, or Steve, you want to go for coffee or
“如果我明天离开这个地方，这里没一个人会拨我的电话，或者说：‘史蒂夫，你想去喝杯咖啡或者……’”
Dinner? It's like that anywhere.
“晚餐？”
That's right, and that's what I can't stand about this place.
“那是肯定的，这就是我无法忍受这个地方的原因。”
Keith, he says, is one of the two people in the world he considers a true friend, someone who'd live for him if need be. At their last meeting, Keith asked Steve if he can give him some explosives, called quarter sticks. There's a guy he wants to teach a lesson to. Steve is so casually generous about it, as if Keith has just asked him for a piece of gum.
他说，基思是世界上他认为的两个真正的朋友之一，如果需要，愿意为他牺牲的人。在最后一次会面中，基思问史蒂夫能不能给他一些爆炸物，叫“四分之一棒”。有个家伙他想教训一下。史蒂夫对此漫不经心地大方，就像基思刚刚向他要一块口香糖。
Can you grab me two, three quarter sticks?
“你能给我两、三根四分之一棒吗？”
Keith, I can give you one now. I used my last one coming down Troy Road Saturday night with--
“基思，我现在能给你一根。我周六晚上开着车下特洛伊路时用了最后一根……”
Steve tosses Keith an explosive he'd been storing behind a fake plant on top of his filing cabinet. And remember, Steve's office is in a middle school. So through the wall, there are kids 10, 12, 13 years old, and the thing is just sitting there, packed with more than 17 grams of incredibly volatile flash powder, 300 times more powerful than the strongest commercially-available firework. That was on a Wednesday. On Friday morning, cops swarmed the pen and arrested Steve. They had to.
史蒂夫扔给基思一枚他一直藏在档案柜顶上假植物后面的爆炸装置。记住，史蒂夫的办公室在中学里。所以墙的那边，就是10岁、12岁、13岁的孩子，而那个东西就放在那里，塞满了17克多极易挥发的闪光粉，比最强的商用烟花威力大300倍。那是周三的事。周五早上，警察突袭了“围栏”并逮捕了史蒂夫。他们必须这么做。
A longtime employee with the Schenectady City School District is in jail without bail tonight. The facilities director is accused of setting off an explosion outside a house. Police say they also found explosives in his office on school grounds.
“斯克内克塔迪市学区的一名长期雇员今晚在没有保释的情况下入狱。设施主任被指控在一所房子外引爆了一个爆炸装置。警方称他们还在校舍内的办公室里发现了爆炸物。”
Superintendent Eric Ely called a news conference the following Monday saying he was shocked-- shocked-- to find out Steve Raucci was a thug.
督导埃里克·伊利在接下来的周一召开新闻发布会，称他很震惊——震惊——发现史蒂夫·劳奇竟然是个恶棍。
My reaction is shock. Certainly concern for the safety of our employees, as well as our students.
“我的反应是震惊。当然，关心我们员工以及学生的安全。”
Many people I talked to said this enraged them, that Ely claimed ignorance about Steve's behavior. Ely politely declined to talk to me for this story. He's still facing lawsuits from former employees. But he gave an extended interview to the local CBS reporter, Marci Natale. He said he thought workers' complaints of Ross's tyranny were overblown.
我采访的许多人说这让他们非常愤怒，因为伊利声称对史蒂夫的行为一无所知。伊利礼貌地拒绝就这个故事与我交谈。他仍然面临前员工的诉讼。但他接受了当地CBS记者马西·纳塔莱（Marci Natale）的深度采访。他说他认为工人对劳奇暴政的投诉被夸大了。
I just have a conceptual problem with, if you're really afraid of somebody, why do you work with him in his home? Why do you invite him to parties? Why do you ask him to get your son a job? Why do you ask favors of him, if you're afraid of him?
“我只是有一个概念上的问题，如果你真的害怕某人，为什么你会和他一起在家工作？为什么你会邀请他参加派对？为什么你会让他给你的儿子找工作？如果你害怕他，为什么要让他帮你忙？”
As for the people who came to Ely for help, like Gary DiNola, Ely said it wasn't his role to solve these problems.
至于那些向伊利求助的人，比如加里·迪诺拉，伊利说解决这些问题不是他的职责。
Well, you know, some people say that you didn't do anything, that you turned your head.
“嗯，你知道，有些人说你什么都没做，你转过头去。”
Well, yeah, they lied. People are just lying. I won't be the scapegoat for somebody else.
“嗯，是的，他们撒谎了。人们只是在撒谎。我不会为别人的错误承担责任。”
Was Steven Raucci your friend?
史蒂夫·劳奇是你的朋友吗？
No.
“不。”
This is the same man who wrote, "There aren't many that I trust. You are one. Thank you." Ely is now superintendent of a district in Southbridge, Massachusetts.
这就是那个写道：“我不信任的人不多。你是其中之一。谢谢你。”的人。伊利现在是马萨诸塞州绍斯布里奇一个学区的督导。
Raucci was tried on 22 felony counts. The prosecution had DNA evidence, wire recordings. They called 62 witnesses. The defense had two, and one of them was cross-examined so effectively that she ultimately did Raucci's case more harm than good. Raucci's lawyer, Ron De Angelus, didn't want to be interviewed on tape. But he said Raucci was very peaceful, very quiet, not at all how they were making him out to be-- practically a maniac. His argument at trial was essentially that Raucci was a grand exaggerator who liked to take credit for things he didn't do.
劳奇被控22项重罪。检方有DNA证据、录音。他们传唤了62名证人。辩方有两名，其中一名在交叉盘问中被问得非常有效，以至于她最终对劳奇的案子造成的伤害多过帮助。劳奇的律师罗恩·德·安吉卢斯（Ron De Angelus）不想在录音中接受采访。但他说劳奇非常平和、非常安静，根本不像他们描绘的那样——简直是个疯子。他在审判中的论点基本上是说劳奇是个夸大狂，喜欢把不是他做的事归功于自己。
At closing, De Angelus place brightly colored plastic eggs into a basket, one by one, and explained that each egg represented reasonable doubt and a chance to redeem. It was Easter time, he reasoned, a time of hope, a time of renewal, a time that, if you're a Christian and dead, you're going to come back to life. Raucci was convicted on 18 counts and acquitted of four.
在结案陈词中，德·安吉卢斯把鲜艳的塑料蛋一个接一个地放入篮子，解释说每个蛋代表合理的怀疑和赎罪的机会。他辩称，这是复活节期间，一个充满希望的时候，一个更新的时候，一个如果你是基督徒且已经死亡，你就会复活的时候。劳奇被判定18项罪名成立，4项无罪。
At the sentencing hearing, Raucci's victims got a chance to speak to the court-- Laura Balogh, Debbie and Hal Gray, and maintenance supervisor Ron Kriss, who'd had his cars vandalized several times after filing a sexual harassment lawsuit against Steve. They hadn't been physically hurt, but their pain was pretty raw.
在判决听证会上，劳奇的受害者有机会向法庭陈述——劳拉·巴洛、黛比和哈尔·格雷，以及维修主管罗恩·克里斯（Ron Kriss），他在对史蒂夫提起性骚扰诉讼后汽车被多次破坏。他们没有受到人身伤害，但他们的创伤非常深。
For more than five years, my family and I were terrorized by Steven Raucci.
“五年多来，我和我的家人一直受到史蒂夫·劳奇的恐吓。”
Just imagine, if you will, how it would be for you to live in fear for yourself, your family, and your property 24 hours a day, seven days a week, for five years.
“试想一下，如果你必须每天24小时、每周7天生活在对你自己、家人和财产的恐惧中，五年之久，那会是什么感觉。”
At night, I don't walk past a window without thinking someone is looking in, or open my windows to experience fresh air.
“晚上，我走过窗户时，总觉得有人在往里看，或者不敢打开窗户感受新鲜空气。”
I tried everything that I could to help those employees at the school district who were being tormented by him, but no one would help me-- not anyone in the union, and not on the school board.
“我尝试了我所能做的一切来帮助学区里那些被他折磨的员工，但没人帮我——工会里没人，学校董事会也没人。”
And then there is my son, who to this day will not sleep in his bed alone. Talks almost every day since the attack as to how he could have stopped it from happening, what violent actions he would have then taken, or could now take, given the chance.
“还有我的儿子，直到今天他都不敢独自在床上睡觉。自从袭击发生后，他几乎每天都在谈论他本可以如何阻止这一切发生，他当时本可以采取什么暴力行动，或者如果给他机会，他现在可以采取什么行动。”
This terrorism has had a dramatic impact on my relationship with my wife. We both have changed. The relationship is strained easily. My wife's emotions have significant swings. And she is not the woman as I knew.
“这种恐怖主义对我和妻子的关系产生了戏剧性的影响。我们俩都变了。关系很容易紧张。妻子的情绪波动很大。她已经不是我认识的那个女人了。”
We developed our own plan for survival. When the alarm would go off, my husband would pull me to the floor, on his side of the bed, and he'd grab the loaded rifle from under the bed and he'd go downstairs. And I would make the 911 call from the cell phone. I never know whether or not my husband would return because thoughts went through my mind of him bombing the front door, or setting our house on fire as we slept, something he said he would do to us.
“我们制定了自己的生存计划。当警报响起时，我丈夫会把我拉到床下的地板上，在他那一侧，他会从床下拿过上了膛的步枪，下楼去。我会用手机打911。我从不知道我丈夫是否会回来，因为我脑子里闪过他炸毁前门，或者在我们睡觉时放火烧房子的念头，他说过他会那样对我们。”
For me, and in front of this court and God, there is no forgiveness for this.
“对我而言，在法庭和上帝面前，这件事没有任何宽恕的余地。”
It was really moving--
真的非常感人——
Carl Strock, the Daily Gazette columnist, watched the trial.
《日报公报》专栏作家卡尔·斯特罗克观看了审判。
To see how they went through this experience. It was fascinating. And they say, you like to think you'd be different. You like to think that I would have done something different if I'd been in that position. I would have stood up. I would have been righteous. But you don't know until you're in that position. You can't be sure.
“看到他们经历了这种体验。这太引人入了。你说，你喜欢认为自己会与众不同。你喜欢认为如果我处于那个位置，我会做些不同的事。我会站出来。我会变得正义。但直到你身处那个位置，你才知道。你无法确定。”
Some of the people who worked for Steve Raucci also thought they'd be different. They were good people. They knew right from wrong. But they tell me that you had to be in it to understand. Ellen Frederick said it was almost like being in a cult, being brainwashed.
一些为史蒂夫·劳奇工作的人也认为他们会与众不同。他们是好人。他们知道对错。但他们告诉我，你必须亲历其中才能理解。艾伦·弗雷德里克说这几乎就像身处邪教之中，被洗脑了。
Raucci was sentenced to spend 23 years at the Clinton Correctional Facility, a prison so far north, so forbidding, so antiquated that a journalist who visited there told me he expected Boris Karloff to walk in any minute. Raucci's working as a clerk in the prison commissary. He'll be up for parole in 2032, when he's in his 80s. Raucci's own father died in prison. And in the past, Raucci had warned darkly that he'd never let that happen to him. Steve was never technically fired, by the way, so he's still entitled to his school pension-- $80,000 a year.
劳奇被判在克林顿惩教所服刑23年，那是一个位于北方极远、令人望而生畏且陈旧的监狱，一位去过那里的记者告诉我，他甚至期望波里斯·卡洛夫（Boris Karloff）随时走进来。劳奇在监狱的小卖部担任职员。他将在2032年获得假释机会，那时他已经80多岁了。劳奇自己的父亲死在监狱里。过去，劳奇曾阴暗地警告说他永远不会让那种事发生在自己身上。顺便说一句，史蒂夫在技术上从未被解雇，所以他仍然有权领取他的学校养老金——每年80,000美元。
Meanwhile, Schenectady cleaned house. The top pro-Raucci administrators are gone-- superintendent Eric Ely to Massachusetts, human resources director Mike Stricos goes to Vegas, and assistant superintendent for business Mike San Angelo-- still nearby, but his contract wasn't renewed. There's an interim superintendent now, a well-liked educator and father of six from another district, whose minivan, incidentally, was set on fire in his driveway one night in 1996. Raucci wasn't questioned in that case, but Carney said he wouldn't be surprised if Steve had been involved.
与此同时，斯克内克塔迪进行了大清洗。劳奇的顶级支持者行政人员都不在了——督导埃里克·伊利去了马萨诸塞州，人力资源总监迈克·斯特里科斯去了拉斯维加斯，业务助理督导迈克·圣安吉洛（Mike San Angelo）——仍然在附近，但他的合同没有续签。现在有一位临时督导，是一位受欢迎的教育家，来自另一个学区，育有六个孩子，顺便说一句，他的小型货车曾在1996年的一晚在家门前的车道上被纵火。在那起案件中，劳奇没有受到质询，但卡尼说如果史蒂夫参与其中，他一点也不会感到惊讶。
School board president Jeff Janiszewski was shouted down by audience members at a couple of meetings. And almost all the old board members, including Janiszewski are gone, either retired or voted out, replaced by self-described reformers. Finally, management of all CSEA union locals in Schenectady County has been taken over by the region until further notice. And at least six people have lawsuits pending.
学校董事会主席杰夫·雅尼谢夫斯基在几次会议上被听众呼喊下台。几乎所有旧董事会成员，包括雅尼谢夫斯基，都离开了，要么退休，要么被投票罢免，取而代之的是自称改革派的人。最终，斯克内克塔迪县所有CSEA工会分部的管理权已由地区接管，直至另行通知。至少有六个人正在起诉中。
When you see pictures of Raucci from the trial, sitting there quietly at the defendant's table, it's hard to imagine that he caused this mayhem all by himself. But of course, he didn't. He was surrounded, above and below, by people who looked the other way. Even Carl Strock, the newspaper columnist, told me, regretfully, that he, too, had gotten complaints about Steve Raucci from maintenance workers in the past, but didn't really follow up. And it's understandable why. Their stories seemed too small and bureaucratic, not something the rest of us would be interested in.
当你在审判照片中看到劳奇安静地坐在被告席上时，很难想象他竟然独自制造了这些混乱。但当然，他没有。他被上方和下方的人包围，这些人视而不见。甚至报纸专栏作家卡尔·斯特罗克也遗憾地告诉我，他过去也从维修工那里收到过关于史蒂夫·劳奇的投诉，但并没有真正跟进。原因是可以理解的。他们的故事看起来太小、太官僚了，不是我们其他人会感兴趣的东西。
Sarah Koenig is now the host of Serial. If you haven't heard season three, it's back to the criminal justice system like season one, but goes so much further, at serialpodcast.com or wherever you get your podcasts.
莎拉·科尼格现在是《Serial》的主持人。如果你还没听过第三季，它像第一季一样回归了刑事司法系统，但走得更远，请访问serialpodcast.com或在任何你获取播客的地方收听。
In the years since we first broadcast this story, the CSEA union locals in Schenectady County have all been restructured. All the officers were replaced. The superintendent of schools there, Eric Ely, as Sarah reported in her story, got another job as a superintendent in Southbridge, Massachusetts, but since then-- since she did this story-- just three years into the job, he resigned after allegations of misconduct. One of the allegations against him? That he trained a middle high school principal to be a bully. He now teaches math at a high school in North Carolina.
在我们第一次播出这个故事后的几年里，斯克内克塔迪县的CSEA工会分部都进行了重组。所有官员都被撤换了。正如莎拉在故事中报道的那样，那里的学校督导埃里克·伊利在马萨诸塞州绍斯布里奇又找到了一份督导工作，但从那以后——在她做这个故事之后——他在职仅仅三年，就因不当行为指控辞职了。对他的一项指控是什么？他培训了一名初中校长去当恶霸。他现在在北卡罗来纳州的一所高中教数学。
Several lawsuits were filed by people who say they were victimized by Raucci, some of them against Steve Raucci, some of them against the school district. Several of those have settled. And finally, as I mentioned at the beginning of the show, 10 years after his arrest, Steve Raucci gave an interview to a newspaper reporter, Paul Nelson, from the Times Union in Albany. A link to his article at timesunion.com is at our website. In the interview, apparently for the first time, Raucci admitted guilt for some of his crimes-- though not the worst one.
一些声称是劳奇受害者的人提起了多项诉讼，有些针对史蒂夫·劳奇，有些针对学区。其中几起已经和解。最后，正如我在节目开头提到的，在他被捕10年后，史蒂夫·劳奇接受了阿尔巴尼《时代联盟报》（Times Union）记者保罗·尼尔森（Paul Nelson）的采访。在他网站上可以找到文章链接，网址是timesunion.com。在采访中，劳奇显然是第一次承认了部分罪行——尽管不是最严重的那几起。
Did we graffiti Laura Burrel's house? Yes. Did I put an M80 on somebody's windshield and drive away?
“我们要给劳拉·伯雷尔的房子涂鸦吗？是的。我有没有把M80炸弹放在某人的挡风玻璃上然后开车离开？”
Gary DiNola.
加里·迪诺拉。
Yes.
“是的。”
OK.
“好的。”
Yes. Yeah. OK?
“是的。是的。好吗？”
Raucci he said he and his wife talked a lot about whether he's a psychopath, but he said he thought he wasn't, because even when he gets all wound up, he said, he doesn't think he loses control of himself. He doesn't snap and cross the line, though of course, that's not the definition of a psychopath. Raucci said several times during the interview that he always knew that what he was doing was wrong.
劳奇说他和妻子谈论过很多关于他是否是精神病态者的问题，但他表示他认为自己不是，因为即使当他情绪激动时，他说，他不认为自己失去了对自己的控制。他并没有崩溃并越界，尽管当然，这不是精神病态者的定义。劳奇在采访中多次表示，他一直知道他在做的事情是错的。
I know they were wrong. I knew what I was doing was wrong. Yeah.
“我知道那是错的。我知道我在做的事情是错的。是的。”
But why'd you do it, then?
“那你为什么要这么做？”
And I knew I could get arrested for it, but-- and I swear to God I wish they could give me a lie detector for this and everything-- I thought the worst that could happen was, oh, yeah, I know I'm going to get arrested. But you don't go to prison for property damage. That's what's going through my-- I'm just thinking, this was property damage. Graffiti-ing a house, dump paint on the car. I didn't think of those as prison sentences. I didn't think that I could end up in a place like this over that.
“我知道我会因为这个被捕，但是——我向上帝发誓，我希望他们能让我做测谎仪测试——我以为最坏的结果不过是，哦，是的，我知道我要被捕了。但你不会因为财产损失坐牢。这就是我当时——我只是想，这只是财产损失。在房子上涂鸦，把油漆倒在车上。我没想到那些会带来监狱刑期。我没想到我会因为那个住进这种地方。”
I mean, I'm not stupid. I wouldn't have done it if I thought that was-- I actually chose the method I chose because I thought I couldn't go to prison.
“我的意思是，我不傻。如果我知道那是——我其实选择了我的方法，因为我以为我不会坐牢。”
So you thought it out, then. It was somewhat premeditated. You thought it out.
“所以你思考过了，那是预谋的。你考虑过了。”
Well, yes. I thought out that I was never going to hurt anybody. That was for damn sure. That's why it was a car in the driveway, or a house. No, I never intended to hurt anybody or anything like that.
“嗯，是的。我考虑过我永远不会伤害任何人。那绝对是肯定的。这就是为什么它是车道上的车，或者房子。不，我从没打算伤害任何人，诸如此类的事。”
Raucci told the reporter that he's been diagnosed with prostate cancer. But he said he doesn't see the point in getting treated, or prolonging his life in a maximum security prison.
劳奇告诉记者他被诊断出患有前列腺癌。但他表示他看不出治疗的意义，也不想在高度安全监狱里延长生命。
[MUSIC - "WORKING CLASS HERO" BY OZZY OSBOURNE]
[音乐 - 奥兹·奥斯本 (Ozzy Osbourne) 的《工人阶级的英雄》]
Well, like, you're not my type. I like Matthew McConaughey. He's my type, whatever. Well, you thought that I just told him I put the knife right in his heart.
“嗯，就像，你不是我的菜。我喜欢马修·麦康纳。他是我的菜，随便吧。”嗯，你以为我只是告诉他，我把刀插进了他的心脏。
(HOST) IRA GLASS I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
（主持人）艾拉·格拉斯：我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。